I love playing characters to be able to  play a 2000 year old vampire kind of  jump to that opportunity I did that  because I'm trying to impress you  Thomas Doherty was a an incredible find  for us when you're in his orbit you are  absolutely sucked into it I want to go  home  but this is your home  I like to break his character into two I  always think of him as Walter and then  develop to Evie  a new bride for me the best thing to do  to embody the character is to have the  the weight and the heaviness in my eyes  it comes from there everything else kind  of comes from that  and there's obviously like a confidence  and then annoyingness think about what  you are gaining here  wealth  power